สวัสดีค่ะครูเลียมสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนใช่สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนนะ
คะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน่วันนี้เจอกันวัน
อะไรอีกแล้วคะครูฟ้าวันนี้เจอกันวันพุธ
ค่ะวันพุธวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่
21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายนนี่เขียนแบบย่อเขียนแบบย่อให้นัย
ปีอะไรคะพ.ศปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศล่ะคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะอืกี่โมงแล้วคะครูป๊าตอนนี้เวลา
1433 นาโอเค
1433 นาททีแล้วนะคะครูฟ้าวันนี้รู้สึก
แบบอยากทำอะไรสนุกๆค่ะครู
ฟ้าอยากทำอะไรสนุกๆครูเรียมอยากทำอะไรอ่ะ
อยากอะไเป็นอะไรที่ไม่ใช่เรียมอยากเป็น
อะไรที่ไม่ใช่ครูเรียม
เดี๋ยวอยากเป็นอะไรที่ไม่ใช่ครูเรียมคือ
อะไรเราก็ต้องอยากเป็นตัวเรามยเราอยาก
เป็นอย่างอื่นได้ด้วยหรอเราเราเป็นตัวเรา
มาแบบนานแล้วอ่ะนานแล้วใช่มยอยากเป็น
อย่าง
อื่นอยากเป็นอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้าเคยคิดมั้ยว่า
ถ้าวันนึงเราได้เป็น
นกอืจิ๊บๆๆๆๆๆๆแล้วก็บินได้
อุ๊ยเคยคเราจะไปทำ
อะไรว่าเคยอยากเป็นนกนะคะนักเรียนอใช่มย
นักเรียนเคยอยากเป็นนกมครูฟ้าคิดว่าถ้า
ครูฟ้าเป็นนกครูฟ้าจะทำอะไร
ถ้าครูฟ้าเป็น
นกครูฟ้าจะบินไปทั่วๆประเทศไทยออคครูพะ
ไม่บินไปแบบลาวเวียดนามออสเตรเลียบินใน
ไทยบินในไทยก่อนค่ะบินในไทยก่อนถ้าครูฟ้า
บินในไทยได้แล้วครูฟ้าค่อยบินไปที่อื่นนะ
คะ
อืบินในประเทศไทยอจะบินไปดูวิวในประเทศ
ไทยอูยเดี้อเป็นนกไม่ต้องเสียเงินซื้อต
เครื่องบินนะอืมเป็นตงต้องขึ้นเครื่องบิน
นะคะไม่ต้องไปไทยแ Airway หรือว่าอะไรไม่
ต้องขึ้นเครื่องบินใช่มั้ยดีนะคะเป็นนก
เนี่ยอืสุดยอดดีมากอืเรมก็คิดนะว่าถ้า
เป็นนกหรออืถ้าคถ้าเป็นนกเตมก็จะทำคล้ายๆ
คูฟ้านะก็จะ
บินอืบินไปเที่ยว
อืบินไปสวนองุ่นแล้วก็ไปกินองุ่นครูบินู
ครูบินใคระครูเหรียมจะบินไปครูบินคือใคร
คูเรียมจะบินไปสวนองุ่นในไทยอ่ะเหรอใช่ใน
ไทยก็มีมีองุ่นน่ะสวนองุ่นเหรอครูเรียม
เออเราก็ไปกินองุ่นไงครูฟ้าอยากกินอะไร
อ่ะพูดมาซิครูฟ้าอยากกิน
สตอเบอร์รี่ใช่ครูฟ้าก็บินไปสวน
สตรอเบอร์รี่อือืเอื้อดีจังเลยอ่ะเป็นนก
อ่ะเป็นนกอ่ะดีเนาะมีปีกไงเราบินได้เรามี
ปีกใช่ๆแล้วทำอะไรได้อีก
น่าไปที่ไหนก็ได้กินผลไม้ที่ไหนก็ไปได้
อืมใช่
ค่ะคุณเรียมก็เลยอยากเป็นนกหรอเมอันนี้
แค่ 1 อย่างนะที่อยากเป็นอืแค่วันนี้อยาก
รู้สึกว่าอยากเป็นอย่างอื่นเฉยๆแต่ไม่รู้
จะเป็นอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้าอ้าวแล้วครูเรียมจะ
เป็นอะไรอีกครูเรียมไม่รู้เหรอคะให้ครู
ฟ้าเลือกดีกว่าเราจะได้ตอบคำถามด้วยกัน
ได้ค่ะครู 1-7 ให้ครูฟ้าเลือก
1-7 ได้
เลยให้ครูฟ้าเลือก 1-7 ใช่มยใช่เอาอะไรดี
1  2  3  4  5  6  7 ครูฟ้าเลือกเบอร์ 3
ค่ะเบอร์ 3 เ
3 วาฬ
[เพลง]
โอ้ถ้าวันนี้เราเป็นวาฬอืเราจะทำอะไรถ้า
วันนี้เป็นวาฬเหรอคะอืมครูฟ้า
เนี่ยชอบ
ทะเลไม่ได้ชอบไปทะเลนะครูฟาไม่ได้ชอบไป
เดินทะเลใส่บิกินี่อะไรูไม่ได้ชอบแบบนั้น
แต่หมายถึงถึงครูฟ้าชอบบทะเลแบบข้างล่าง
อ่ะนะคะครูฟ้าชอบข้างล่างครูฟ้าว่ายน้ำ
เป็นมั้ยครูฟ้าว่ายน้ำเป็นค่ะว่ายน้ำเป็น
แล้วครูฟ้าก็เลยชอบแบบใต้ทะเลเราเรียกว่า
ใต้ทะเลนะคะนักเรียนอืะอยากรู้
ว่าใต้ทะเลอ่ะมี
อะไรอืถ้าเกิดครูฟ้าเป็นวาฬเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็
จะลงไปข้างล่างใช่มยลงไปใต้ทะเลนะคะข้าง
ล่างแล้วก็ไปดูว่าในทะเลมีอะไรบ้างมีปลา
อะไรบ้างแล้วก็ไปดูอะไรหลายๆอย่างในทะเล
เพว่าเป็นคนชอบใต้ทะเลมากๆอือจริงๆอือ๋อ
ครูฟ้าอยากไปว่ายน้ำในทะเลลึกไปดูใช่มยอื
ไปดู้าเป็นเหลี่ยมเหรอถ้าเป็นเลียมเรียม
จะลองแบบหาอาหารน่ะทำไมเลียมเข้าแต่
เรื่องกินตลอดเลยเพะว่าวานแบบเ้าจะกินปลา
ปลาตัวเล็กๆใช่มยหรือว่าอาจจะตัวใหญ่ก็
ได้เจะก็จะอ้าปากอืแล้วปลาก็จะเข้ามามัน
มันน่าจะเหมือนซาชิมิอะไรอย่างงี้มั้ยเออ
ไม่รู้อ่ะเวลากินอาหารใช่มยอจะเป็นยังไง
นั่นสินะฮะตวาฬมันต้องอยู่ตัวเดียวนะปู
เหลี่ยมอืแต่ว่าครูฟ้าคะถ้าเกิดมีคนแบบ
นั่งเรือไปแล้วก็ไปเห็นครูฟ้า
ป่าวฟาวานแล้วก็ถ่ายรูปูฟ้าแช
แชะจะโอเคมยเหรอหรือก็โอเคนะก็ไม่เป็นไร
นะอ้าก็ไม่เป็นไรเหรอครูฟ้าต้องแบบตกใจ
มั้ยก็อาจจะตกใจนะคะถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นปลาหวาน
ครูฟ้า
ก็ไม่ได้อยากอยู่กับคนมั้งคงจะไปไปไกลๆคน
นะคะเพราะว่าคนน่ากลัวใช่มยคนครูฟ้าครู
เรียมเป็นคนนักเรียนก็เป็นคนนะคะถ้าเรา
ถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นวานครูฟ้าก็คงจะอยู่ในน้ำ
นั่นแหละอยู่ในน้ำอขึ้นมาไม่ได้ขึ้ขึ้นมา
ไม่ได้ครูฟ้าครูเลียมอินเทอร์เน็ตครูฟ้า
โอเคมั้ยของเลียมโอเคนะครูฟ้าเห็นเลียม
กระตุกหรอกระตุกแบบูฟ้าไม่เห็นครูเหลี่ม
แล้วจริงหรอเออเรียมเห็นสุโอเคเห็นแล้ว
ค่ะเห็นลเห็นแล้วโอเคอืโอเคถ้าอย่างงั้น
อันนี้คือปลาวาฬใช่มยใช่ก็ปลาหวานครู
เรียมอยากทำอะไรอีกมั้ยคะไม่นะก็แบบเออก็
ไม่มีอะไรหรอกก็แค่ดำน้ำลงไปดูใต้ทะเลดู
ปลาดู
ปะการังอืแค่นั้นเองเราไปเป็นอย่างอื่นดี
กว่าครูฟ้าเราเลือกได้เยอะเลยได้ค่ะได้
ได้เลยเต็มให้ครูฟ้าเลือกอีกอมี 1  2  4
5  6  7  1  2  4  5  6  7 ูพระเอาเบอร์
7 จริง
หรอูว่าไม่ชอบจิ้งจกอันนี้คือตุ๊กแกอัน
นี้ตุ๊กแกอนี้ตุ๊กแกเออๆอนี้คือตุ๊กแกมัน
คล้ายๆจิ้งจกนะคะแต่เดียล่ะตุ๊แกยังโอเค
กว่าถ้าครูฟ้าได้เป็นตุ๊แกครูฟ้าจะทำอะไร
ถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นตุ๊กแกเหรอคะ
ใช่ครูฟ้าจะเข้าไปในห้องน้ำที่มีคนอยู่
ค่ะครูิครูฟ้าครูฟ้าทำไมแบบเป็นคนแบบนี้
ทำไมเป็นตุ๊กแกแบบนี้เพราะว่านักเรียนคน
ไทยอ่ะกลัวตุ๊กแกเนาะส่วนใหญ่นะคนไทยหลาย
ๆคนกลัวตุ๊กแกตุ๊กแกมันน่ากลัวใช่มยบางคน
ไม่ชอบตุ๊กแกแล้วตุ๊กแกมันก็กัด
กัดได้นะมันกัดด้วยค่ะถ้าครูฟ้าเป็น
ตุ๊กแกแล้วครูฟ้าเออทำยังไงวิ่งไปหาคน
แล้วคนกลัวครูฟ้าน่าจะสนุกนั่นไงครูฟ้า
รู้ใช่มยว่าตุ๊กแกทำไมถึงวิ่งหาคนนั่นน่ะ
สิหรือว่าตุ๊กแกมันรู้คว่าคนกลัวมันก็เลย
อุ้ยคนกลัวเราเราก็วิ่งไปหาคนคนจะได้กลัว
ก็สนุกดีนะแต่ตอนที่เป็นคนก็แบบโอ๊ย
ตุ๊กแกอืกอยู่ในห้องน้ำก็ไม่กล้าเข้าห้อง
น้ำโหน่ากลัวมากตุ๊กแกจริง
ๆถ้าเรียมเป็นตุ๊กแกนะแหลถ้าูเรียมเป็น
ตุ๊กแกเรียมก็จะลองขึ้นไปบนเพดาน
ดูทำไมอ่ะเดมอยากเห็นแบบโลกอีกมุมมองนึง
อ่ะไแบบมองครูฟ้าแบบเนี้ยเออเนาะมองูฟ้า
แบบจากอีกมมองนึงอ่ะอือๆๆอยากรู้ว่าแบบ
แบบตุ๊กแกวิวอ่ะตุ๊แกวิวิวครู้าเคยได้ยิน
แบบเดอายวิวมยเคยค่ะเออ Bird  E วิอยากดู
แบบตุ๊กแกวิวอืออ้อน่าสนใจนะเหมือน
สไปเดอร์แมนอ่ะสใจเออใช่ๆๆอืแต่ว่าแบบ
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าเท้าของตุ๊กแกใช่ไมม
ตุ๊กแกก็จะมีเท้ามีมือนะคะเนี่ยมือมือมือ
เนี่ยสามารถเกาะกำแพแงได้เกาะเกาเกาเก
เออเหมือนสไปเดอร์แมนเลยใช่โหูสุดยอดอือ
ได้เป็นตุ๊กแกครูฟ้าจะไม่ลองร้องเหมือน
ตุ๊กแกด้วยด้วยหน่อยรอค่ะอุ้ยไม่เอาค่ะ
ไม่อันนี้คือสิ่งที่ไม่อยากทำใช่มั้ยว่า
เกลียดเสียงตุ๊กแกมากนะดีๆๆวันนี้ก็ได้
เป็นทั้งตุ๊กแกได้เป็นปลาวาฬได้เป็นนก
เดี๋ยวว่าเป็นเป็นอีกสักอย่าง 2 อย่างดี
กว่าได้ค่ะครูเหลี่ยมให้ครูป้าเลือง
เหมือนเดิมมั้ยหรือว่าเหลือ 1  2  4  5  6
1  2  4  5  6 ครูปาเอาเลข 1 เลข 1 คือ
อะไรอ่ะ
วคเรืมเปลี่ยนได้มั้ยเดี๋ยวืมปิดภาพให้
อันนี้คือจิ้งจกนะคะูฟ้ากลัวจิ้งจก้ากลัว
จิ้งจกค่ะเดี๋ยวรืมเอาออกให้แต่ว่าจะถาม
ถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นจิ้มจกครูพ้าจะทำอะไรครูฟ้า
คิดว่าครูฟ้าน่า
จะถ้าเป็นจิ้งจกเหรอวิ่งหาคน
มั้ยไม่เอาอ่ะเพราะว่าจิ้งจกตัวเล็กอ๋ออ
จิ้งจกตัวเล็กมันถ้าวิ่งไปหาคนเราอาจจะ
ตายก็
ได้เราอาจจะตายก็ได้นะคะแต่ว่าถ้าเป็น
จิ้งจกครูฟ้าก็คง
จะเข้าไปในห้องหลายๆห้องได้มยเพราะว่าคน
เนี่ยในบ้านคนมันจะมีมีบ้านแล้วก็จะมี
ห้องใช่มั้ยคะห้องนอนห้องน้ำห้องนั่งเล่น
ถ้าเราเป็นจกเนี่ยเราก็สามารถเข้าไปใน
ห้องที่มันล็อคได้ไงอืหลายๆห้องที่มัน
ล็อคเนี่ยมันจะมีรูเล็กๆใช่มยแล้วจิ้งจบ
ก็จะเข้าไปได้คงเข้าไปเที่ยวในห้องหลายๆ
ห้องที่มันล็อคนะคะแล้วก็จะไปหลายๆบ้านอื
ไปเที่ยวครูฟ้าพูดขึ้นมาแบบนี้เรียมแบบ
รู้สึกแบบเกลียดจิ้งจกขึ้นมาที่มันเข้ามา
ในบ้านได้เนี่ยเออมันั้นเพราะว่ามันมีรู
เล็กๆไงจิ้งจกก็จะวิ่งเข้าในบ้านของเรา
ถ้าครูฟ้าอยากแบบเข้าไปห้องได้หลายๆห้อง
ถ้าเป็นจิ้งจกนะครูฟ้าต้องระวังเวลาคนที่
เา้าเปิดติดประตูอ่ะ
ใช่นักเรียนประเทศไทยเนี่ยจิ้งจกเยอะนะคะ
นักเรียนไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนรู้จัก
จิ้งจกมยอแต่จิ้งจกในไทยก็จะเย
ละตายเพราะว่าโดนประตูประตูใช่มยนี่คือ
ประตูเออประตูหนีบนะคะใช่โดนประตูหนีบตาย
ครูฟ้าถ้าเป็นจิ้งจกต้องระวังระวังประตู
หนีบประตูหนีบโอเคอ่ะไม่รู้พูดอะไรกันนะ
เออถ้าอย่างงั้นเราเปลี่ยนมั้ยคะครูเรียม
เปลี่ยนๆเดี๋ยวเรียมเลือกดีกว่าได้ให้ครู
เรียมเลือกเรียมเลือกอ่ะถ้าเป็น
ยุงถ้าเป็นยุงหรอเอเราอ่ะคิดแต่แบบเวลา
เราเป็นคนใช่มยเราก็คิด
จากคนคิดอะไรกับอย่างอื่นแต่อันนี้ถ้าเรา
เปลี่ยนตัวเองไปเป็นยุงอืูฟ้าจะทำยังไง
ครูฟ้าคงต้อง
รีบรีบทำอะไรเร็วๆนะคะเพราะว่ายุงเนี่ย
อยู่ได้ 7 วันใช่มโอ้แล้วยุงก็จะ
ตายอือก็ปจะไปกินเลือดคนอื่นมั้ยมันก็คง
ต้องกินค่ะเพราะว่าเราต้องกินเพื่อให้มี
ชีวิตใช่มเพื่อให้ไม่ตายนะคะูฟ้าอาจจะไป
กินเลือดยุงเนี่ยกินเลือดนะนักเรียนกิน
เลือดยุงหรือแิเนี่ยหรือแวมไพร์นะคะมายุง
กกินเลือดสปีชีเดียวกันหรือเปล่าูฟ้าูฟ้า
คิดว่าระหว่างที่ไม่กินเลือดคนกับมากัด
แล้วก็ดูดเลือดกินเลือดคนเนี่ยอันไหนตาย
เร็วกว่ากันกินเลือดคนตายเลยนะคะเพราะว่า
คนจะตีอืตียุงใช่มยถ้าครูฟ้าไปกินเลือดคน
คนก็จะตีนะคะก็เลยใช่เป็นยุงทำอะไรอ่ะเออ
เกิดเป็นยุงก็ลำบากนะเนี่ยอือเป็นยุงก็คง
ลำบากนะกินเลือดของคน
ที่กินเลือดในโรงพยาบาลได้มั้ยคุณ้าเร็ม
รู้มั้ยเร็มนึกอะไรออกู้ฟ้ากินเลือดหมา
อะไรเงี้ยหมาินเลือดหกเรียวนั่นน่ะสิกัด
เลือดหมาได้
มั้ยหมานะนหมาแบบหุ่งๆอ่ะหหมันตบไม่ได้
อ่ะอืแต่คนตบแล้วตายนะูพ้าต้อง
เลือกไม่ไหวเลยค่ะคิดไม่ออกนะถ้าเป็นครู
เลียมล่ะครูเลียมจะทำอะไรถ้าเป็นเลียมหรอ
เออถ้าถ้าเรียมเป็นยุงที่ฉลาดนะเรียมก็คง
ไปกินเลือดอย่างอื่นที่ไม่ใช่เลือดคนอื
กินเลือดหมากินเลือด
แสงสารหมาแมวเออเออแต่เป็นยูงไง
ยุงเหมือนเลยตอนเนี้ยเหมือนมากเลยใส่คุ
เรียมใส่ชุดสีดำเหมือน
ยุง
เหมือนเหมือนใส่เสื้อสีดำอ่ะยุงตัวสีดำ
อ่ะเหมือนยุงเลยตอนเนี้ยอือใช่ก็เออก็แบบ
เออประสบการณ์ใหม่นะถ้าเป็นยุงยก็บินได้
แต่บินไม่ได้ไกลอืบินในบ้านบินรอบๆบ้าน
อือเออเตรียมว่าบินได้นิดหนื่อยอืไม่ไม่
กินเลือดคนแน่นอนกลัวตาย
เร็วใช่ค่ะน่ากลัวเหมือนกันนะเป็นยุง
เนี่ยตลกค่ะแล้วก็แบบเรายังมีเวลาอยู่
เนาะครูฟ้าใช่มยดิมอยากดิมอยากให้ครูฟ้า
เป็นอีกอันนึงอ่ะเอาแบบน่ารักๆได้ค่ะเรา
ยังเหลือเวลากี่นาที
อโอ้าครูฟ้าเป็น
กระต่ายกระต่ายกระต่าย
หื้าครูฟ้าเป็นกระต่าย
หรอใช่เป็น
กระต่ายกระต่ายเนี่ยครูฟ้าจะทำตัวน่ารักๆ
นะ
คะเพราะว่าครูจะได้ไปอยู่กับคนดีๆใช่มยคน
ที่ไม่กินกระต่ายนะคะนักเรียนมันก็จะมีคน
ที่กินกระต่ายและคนที่ไม่กิน
กระต่ายคนไทยไม่กินกระต่ายคือไม่ค่อยเห็น
นะคนกินกระต่ายอืมคนไทยไม่กินกระต่ายนะคะ
แล้ว
ก็คิดว่าถ้าเป็นกระต่ายครูฟ้าก็จะไปลอง
อยู่ใน
ป่าอยู่ในป่าเพราะว่ากระต่ายก็อยู่ในป่า
ใช่มยอืมันจะมีกระต่ายหลายแบบนะคะลองใช้
ชีวิตอยู่ในป่าดูนะคะมันก็อาจจะ survivor
นิดหน่อยเพราะว่ากระต่ายเนี่ยมันตัวเล็กๆ
ตัวเล็กๆมันอาจจะมีสัตว์แบบหมีแบบเสือ
หรือว่าอะไรที่กินกระต่ายอีกทีนึงใช่ไมยอ
าก็เลยจะลองไปใช้ชีวิตแบบ Survival อยู่
ในป่านะคะโหคุณครูฟ้าสุดยอดเลยอ่ะเอออยาก
รู้ไงโอแต่ถ้าเป็นเียมนะถ้าเป็นเียมเป็น
กระต่ายเียมอยากเป็นกระต่ายที่คนเลี้ยง
อ่ะทำไมล่ะคนเลี้ยงใช่ิมก็จะเป็นกระต่าย
ที่แบบคนซื้อบ้าน
ให้อเล่นอยู่ในบ้านอืแล้วก็หิวแล้วคนก็
แบบอ่ะแครอทนิมก็จะเออยิงแครอทเออแต่เป็น
กระต่ายก็ดีนะเพราะว่ากระต่ายกินผลไม้กิน
ผักใช่ไหมมแบบแครอทเนี่ยเป็นผักนะฮะอืก็
กินแค่ 2 อย่างมันก็ Healthy ดิใช่แล้วก็
วิ่งเล่นวิ่งเล่นในบ้านอืๆเออเออแล้วก็มี
คนดูแลอ่ะสมีคนแบบใส่เสื้อผ้าให้กระต่าย
ด้วยนะอืๆแต่งตัวให้กระต่ายใช่เป็นเรื่อง
ปกตินั่นแหละเวว่าอสบายอ่ะเวไม่อยากอยู่
ในป่าแต่อันนั้นครูฟ้าชอบครูฟ้าชอบเพอยาก
ลองไปใช้ชีวิตในป่าดูว่าเพจะตายมั้ย
อออาจจะตายรือเปล่าอาจจะตายเนี่ยเหรออจะ
ตายค่ะกระต่ายมันเป็นสัตว์ตัวเล็กๆไงอื
อาจจะมีงูคอยกินด้วยทีนึงอย่าเงี้ยครูฟา
ครูฟาไม่กลัวงูหรอทำไมอยากเป็นกระต่าย
อยู่ในป่าครูฟ้าอาจจะสู้กับงูได้ก็ได้นะ
คะสุดยอดกระต่ายที่เป็นมวยไทยไงเดี๋ยว
กระต่ายจิงโจ้กระต่ายหรือจิงโจ้
ออสเตรเลียที่กระต่ายที่เป็นมวยไทยนะคะ
เอาไปสู้กับงูต้องลองดูสักครั้งนึงนั่น
แหละโอสุดยอดแต่แบบเป็นก็เว่าแบบเป็นแป๊บ
เดียวอ่ะใช้เวลาเป็นแป๊บเดียวอ่ะสนุกอยู่
ใช่ถ้าให้เป็น Forever มันไม่โอเคเนาะอื
ให้เป็นนานๆก็คิดว่ากลับมาเป็นคนดีกว่าอื
ใช่ค่ะเออียมก็เลยเออเรามาพูดคุยกันแบบ
นี้ก็เลยรู้เลยว่าเออเป็นคนที่ก็สบายที่
สุดแล้วนะเป็นคนที่ทำได้หลายอย่างอืมาก
กว่าที่เป็นอย่างอื่นใช่ค่ะเป็นคนก็
ดีที่สุดหรอก็ไม่รู้ว่าดีที่สุดมแต่ว่า
มันสบายที่สุดเราบอกว่าคนเนี่ยสบายที่สุด
แล้วนะคะพูดได้กินอะไรก็ได้
อืแต่ว่าวันนี้ที่ได้ที่ได้ลองเปลี่ยน
ลิ้นพันกันแล้ววันนี้ที่ได้ลองเปลี่ยน
เป็นสัตว์อื่นก็ดีนะทำให้เรียมและครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเข้าใจสัตว์อื่นๆที่แบบคนทำอะไรกับ
สัตว์อื่นบ้าง
อื
ใช่ค่ะก็ถ้านักเรียนถ้านักเรียนล่ะนัก
เรียนอยากลองเปลี่ยนเป็นสัตว์อะไรถ้านัก
เรียนเปลี่ยนได้นะคะอืแล้วจะทำอะไรอืแล้ว
จะทำอะไรใช่อืใช่แต่วันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วได้
ค่ะถ้าอย่างงั้นเราเจอกันใหม่วดีโอหน้านะ
คะนักเรียนวันนี้ก็บ๊ายบายสวัสดีบ๊ายบาย
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูป๊าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนบ๊าย
บาย